I think that you just have the most
handsome date on the red carpet tonight
introducing possibly the sweetest this
is my son Bennett godly hi Bennett high
hill to be walking the red carpet mama
awesome and also it's not red it's gold
wow that's impressive okay oh just you
know what I've been doing this for like
29 years and you're right and you'll go
back to me for the first time we heard
all about the gold carpet love it high
five on the correction thank you for
keeping me straight Mack Smith yes it's
our big goal tonight it's gonna make it
happen
oh yes because I'm a big fan as well you
can use that as an excuse that's right
that's the whole purpose of the invite
how does it feel to be here tonight on
the ivme bold carpet yes exactly it
feels great
we feel very lucky that our show the
unbreakable Kimmy Schmidt is still in
the mix and we're still nominated for
Best Comedy and because it's our last
season we finished filming so it's all
done so this is like a happy little
reunion for us to come back a little
bittersweet in a way oh no I think it's
more of a celebration actually yeah we
were thrilled to be invited and get to
see each other so we'll have fun inside
go to some of the parties and celebrate
our show tonight are you going to the
parties my mom yes well she wanted me
turn that way thanks see you you're so
cute who else you want to meet I don't
know just doctor who limo didn't way
excited about a limo I think it might
have been the highlight of the evening
for him yeah when you're little um it
was a big thing are you gonna become an
actor too would you want him to start uh
following your footsteps if he has the
need for applause we'll say it I think
he's he seems mentally balanced right
now so he might be okay
you're still thrilled about the limos
you're mentally balanced that's Tina Fey
has teased everybody about
reboot oh she has today today and other
days yes well I think that would be a
hoot I think that would be really really
fun
imagine the the age-defying pressed
range and it would be hungered with a
reunion all these years later but you
you do defy all that so she would be so
perfect about it so that I think there
would be comedy gold there to mine it
would be such a joy for us all to get
back together you know I'm starting a
new show right now and I start work
tomorrow on Wednesday Wednesday
Miriam a new series it's the first time
in 11 years I've not worked for Tina Fey
so I'm like just adjusting and like oh
they do it differently than her okay I'm
gonna get used to this now so you'd be
in if there is a reboot you're in Oh
definite sign me up now
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]